Nadeem touched on the issue of turkey
turkey as president is of course due at
that NATO Summit in Lithuania which
begins tomorrow he is expected once
again to meet the Swedish prime minister
to discuss Stockholm's stalled
application to join the alliance a
diplomatic editor James James Bay is
standing by for us in villainous ahead
of that NATO Summit how much pressure
James is turkey likely to be under to
support Sweden's membership in NATO
because as it stands that's the only
thing holding it back
yes all the other allies well actually
Hungary hasn't ratified yet but Hungary
says it will ratify if Turkey does but
yes real high-stakes talks just on the
very Eve of this Summit and all the NATO
leaders arriving here the Swedish prime
minister is here and now turkey's
president erdogan has just landed in the
last few moments at Vilnius airport for
these talks but of course in recent
hours while speaking in Turkey he's
added a new condition and it's a pretty
big one he is now linking the idea that
Sweden should join NATO and become the
32nd member of NATO with his own
countries stalled it seemed almost
aborted bid to join the European Union I
think that's a big development a big
problem I think for the NATO allies the
other NATO allies and for the NATO
Secretary General Jen stoltenberg that's
this is what he said about it a short
time ago
I support turkey's Ambitions to become a
member of the European Union at the same
time we need to remember that what we
agreed in Madrid was a specific list of
conditions that Sweden has to meet to be
a full member of the alliance and Sweden
has met these conditions and that's
about
removing restrictions on arms exports
that has happened then it's about
strengthening the cooperation between
turkey and
Sweden on fighting terrorism that's
taking place
well that issue the issue of Sweden
joining NATO is one of the problem areas
that is going to be discussed by the
NATO allies as they gather here for the
next couple of days but there are other
issues too I think the atmosphere soured
for some privately they're not saying
very much in public the decision by the
U.S to send cluster Munitions uh to
Ukraine but the other issue is how
exactly the NATO allies handle Ukraine
itself and its aspirations to be a NATO
member they're certainly not going to
make it a NATO member at this Summit but
they need to put some clear language
according to president zielinski that
there's a concrete path for Ukraine to
join NATO they're working even now not
just the negotiations on Sweden but
they're not working even now on the
final language of the communique and
there are differences among the NATO
allies we understand but an important
development in the last couple of hours
the foreign minister of Ukraine dimitro
kaleba has said there's been progress on
one thing and that's that Ukraine should
be able to Fast Track the process
there's something called a membership
action plan which all recent members of
NATO when they've joined have had to go
through and that's an arduous series of
political economic and Military tests
well it looks like Ukraine is going to
be given the opportunity to skip that
process interesting stuff James Bay is
our diplomatic editor speaking to us
there from Vilnius
well let's get some reaction now to what
we've been hearing out of turkey we can
speak to our correspondent resource
photos in Istanbul so we had that result
from James there's this sense in Vilnius
that president erdogan is is making
these new demands in that NATO
membership for Sweden and the EU
membership for turkey are simply two
different issues why has the Turkish
side raise this now what are they hoping
to accomplish
well it's as of now it's not clear
whether this is a demand or a condition
however linking turkey's membership to
European Union to civilian's accession
to Nato is quite a new element now in
all of these negotiations so that is a
very quiet maximalist demand so today
just ahead of flying to Lithuania
president erdogan had a pressure and he
said that turkey has been waiting at the
at the gates of the European Union for
almost around five decades and it's the
time that the European Union gave a
positive signs to turkey's full
membership to European union and that
will also encourage turkey to give the
green light to Sweden's accession to
Nato but as I said it's not clear
whether this is a new condition or he's
trying to convince or encourage European
unions to be more positive toward turkey
but as I said it is quite a new element
and the experts here are saying that one
by coming with this maximalist demands
probably he's aware that turkey's
membership to European Union is not
going to happen anytime soon however he
is trying to secure some of the possible
and moderate concessions such as the
modernization of F-16 fighter jets of
turkey that turkey has been asking but
is still awaiting the approval of the
U.S Senate and also the the Customs
unions agreement to be reformed with the
European Union some of the trade
benefits and also the free visa for the
Turkish citizens to the Schengen area so
if everyone can get these demands or at
least this if his demands are met by
this that's going to be quite a success
for him but why all of these news
developments are happening the
Diplomatic efforts are also being
intensified yesterday we have seen a
phone call between President erdogan and
President Biden so the focus was the
Sweden's accession to Nato and just
three hours ago there has been another
important phone call all between
churches foreign minister and the
Secretary of State Anthony blinken so
that's also the focus was the uh the
membership of Sweden to Nato as of now
the mood here in turkey that turkey is
not going to change his position still
they say that Ankara saying that despite
some of the the positive steps taken by
Sweden it is still not sufficient enough
that turkey can give the green light to
that however if these negotiations
produce a tangible result and if Turkey
gives a green light to civitan's
accession that will be the biggest
surprise of these NATO Summit
Brazil said her there for us in Istanbul